okay so we're given this exponential
equation we've got that variable up
there in the exponent spot the first
thing you can try to do is get the bases
to be the same but two and eighteen
don't really have a common base so we're
gonna have to use logarithms and the
first thing I would do here is I would
take the log of both sides of the
equation now you could take a log base
two you could take a log base 10 it
doesn't really matter but in this case
I'm going to take the log base two of
both sides and the reason I'm doing that
is because log base two an exponential
function with these two those are
inverses they cancel one another out so
we have X plus one now equals log base
two of 18 now all we have to do is just
subtract one from both sides of the
equation so we get x equals negative one
plus log base two of the team don't make
the mistake of subtracting the one from
from the 18 and now you can go to your
calculator and you can simplify now some
calculators don't have the ability to
take the log base two they only have log
base 10 that's the common log or log
base E that's the natural log so you can
write this as log base 10 of 18 over log
base 10 of 2 and then you know add the
negative one and I did this earlier this
came out to four point one seven plus
the negative one so that final answer is
going to be three point one seven
approximately okay approximately three
point one seven if you're new to the
channel or if you're a long time viewer
consider subscribing
you know this channel is all about
making learning math less stressful so
that you can raise your grade pass your
class and go on to pursue your dreams I
look forward to helping you with this
channel with my future videos and I'll
see you in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon